[Musik]
wer dazu imstande ist mit politik den
eigenen erlebnis hunger zu stillen
der ist zurzeit bei der spd genau
richtig das spektakel das die partei
zurzeit auf führt ja das hätte für alle
außenstehenden einen hohen
unterhaltungswert wenn die sache nicht
so ernst wäre es werden hier bereits
erste vergleiche mit dem laufenden
karneval gezogen
aber der ist ja auch bekanntlich eine
durchaus ernste angelegenheit eine
sondereinlage der phoenix runde zum
thema des tages spd in turbulenzen was
kommt nach martin schulz liebe zuschauer
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
angelika hellemann ist bei uns die
stellvertretende politik chefin von bild
am sonntag
klaus peter schmitl geld
kommunikationsberater und politikberater
in dieser funktion auch schon mal einmal
tätig für den früheren spd
finanzminister hans eichel professor
oskar niedermayer politikwissenschaftler
an der freien universität berlin und
gordon repinski leiter des
hauptstadtbüros des redaktions netzwerks
deutschland viele gene tiefe und dieses
aktionsnetzwerk deutschland beliefert
über 30 regionale tageszeitungen mit
inhalten herr schmidt geld es ist noch
kein jahr her da wurde martin schulz in
der eigenen partei wie ein gott verehrt
jetzt wird er vom hof gejagt
schaffen sie es in 30 sekunden uns die
gemütslage einer solchen partei wie der
spd zu erklären
verwirrt wäre optimistisch ich glaube es
ist ziemlich chaotisch und die
mitglieder zumindest aber auch viele
funktionäre offenbar begreift nicht was
da passiert ist und auch was sie selber
angerichtet haben im pinzgau ein genosse
aus hessen hat heute geschrieben die spd
und martin schulz das war die geschichte
eines einjährigen missverständnisses
irgendwie erinnert man sich aber dass
das schon ein paar mal passiert ist mit
parteivorsitzenden der spd und ihre
partei lernt die spd die aus ihren
vielen die alle geschichten sind
unterschiedlich ich glaube die von
martin schulz ist tatsächlich eine
einmalige geschichte der ist innerhalb
eines jahres so hoch geflogen die
kammern
parteivorsitz der kanzlerkandidat in den
vergangenen jahren und dann wieder so
tief abgestürzt wie kein anderer
jetzt diese geschichte so tragisch endet
ist in der tat noch mal etwas besonderes
auch so menschlich tragisch mit dieser
freundschaft die zerbrochen ist zwischen
sigmar gabriel und martin schulz aber am
ende auch ein befreiungsschlag für die
spd und vielleicht die chance wirklich
jetzt nach vorne zu kommen
vor allem an zieht die spd
möglicherweise noch andere parteien mit
ins unglück
das glaub ich erstmal nicht also es die
große frage ist was was die mitglieder
entscheiden wird aber im moment hat die
kanzlerin sogar noch eine kleine
verschnaufpause gekriegt weil einen tag
vorher haben wir sehr auf die cdu
geguckt und ist dies großes rumoren in
der cdu-abgeordnete twitterten ziemlich
böse naja wenigstens das kanzleramt
haben wir noch behalten
es gab eine große unzufriedenheit mit
dem koalitionsvertrag und mit der
aufteilung und dann hat halt die spd die
bühne gestürmt und hat gesagt drama
können wir besser und da alle gucken nur
noch auf die spd und die cdu kann sich
jetzt etwas ruhiger sortieren
niedermaier der koalitionsvertrag der da
in der nacht von dienstag auf mittwoch
verabschiedet worden ist der schien ja
wie maßgeschneidert für martin schulz
sozialdemokratische handschrift außenamt
das außenministerium für ihn dazu noch
das finanzministerium sonst keine groko
hieß es das hätte daran auch scheitern
können
das war also etwas das für martin schulz
sozusagen maßgeschneidert war muss sich
angela merkel jetzt nach diesem rückzug
diesem vollständigen rückzug von schulz
verschaukelt fühlen ja so hat zumindest
maßgeschneidert in bezug auf das
lieblingsprojekt von martin schulz
nämlich europa also ein stärkeres
solidarisches europa und das wäre ja
durchaus mit den beiden ministerien her
möglich gewesen dass die spd da ihre
konzeption von europa sehr viel stärker
durchsetzte und ich glaube auch nicht
dass frau merkel dem großen widerstand
entgegengesetzt hätte hier ein
richtungswechsel in der politik zu
machen wie es jetzt aussieht wird man
sehen weil ja noch vollkommen unklar ist
was nach dem rückzug von martin schulz
dann mit dem außenminister passiert ob
sigmar gabriel jetzt durch seine
kapriolen sozialen gestern sich
endgültig die säure verscherzt hat oder
ob die paar stimmen die jetzt schon für
ihn in die waagschale geworfen werden
dann noch mal was ändern ich glaube es
eher nicht aber es ist schon so dass es
jetzt eine ganz andere lage ist auch für
vormerken rückzüge dritte bedeuten ja
oft eine klärung der lage das kann man
jetzt gerade nicht behaupten von andrea
nahles ist ja heute überliefert dass sie
nicht nur respektiert möglichen
vorgänger im parteivorsitz gezollt hat
sondern sich jetzt auch ein ende der
personaldebatten wünschte ist das ein
frommer wunsch geht es jetzt erst
richtig los ja natürlich ist das ein
frommer wunsch man ja nichts geklärt ist
also wann gibt es jetzt die wirkliche
stabübergabe was wird überhaupt aus
martin schult alles offen also zieht er
sich komplett zurück sie haben nichts
geklärt wie machen die das mit den mit
den regionalkonferenzen
es ist völlig offen ja was jetzt für
minister da sind also olaf scholz aus
hamburg hat halt das ganz ganz ganz
grosse bedürfnis und den wunsch dass man
eben nicht übernahmen spekuliert weil
falls dann der mitgliederentscheid durch
ja schief geht dann kann er wenigstens
in hamburg bleiben das ist halt
schwieriger wenn er vorher gesagt hat
hallo ich will nach berlin und die
partei dann sagt nee wir wollen aber
nicht dass du finanzminister bist und in
einer gruppe oder das umsetzt
das wird natürlich jetzt noch weiter
richtig rund gehen und die große frage
ist die über allem schwebt was ist mit
sigmar gabriel der wird jetzt weiter
versuchen wahrscheinlich sich in
stellung zu bringen
viele termine als außenminister zu
machen und in der parteiführung gibt es
halt eine massive stimmung gegen ihn
weil er seine eigene fünfjährige tochter
gegen einen amtierenden spd vorsitzenden
zu instrumentalisieren
das ist schon etwas das hat es bislang
so noch nicht gegeben also heute haben
führende spd leute darüber gesagt das
hat noch nicht einmal oskar lafontaine
gemacht dass es so das schlimmste was
man in der spd wenn jemand sagen kannst
seine tochter ja angeblich gesagt habe
frühstückstisch
jetzt sei nicht traurig jetzt kannst du
mir bei uns sollen als bei dem man mit
den haaren im gesicht
er schmierte gelb personalfragen
erkennen parteien bekanntlich keine
gnade einmal ganz besonders nicht die
spd beginnen diese turbulenzen jetzt
erst für die partei ich glaube das nicht
also sigmar gabriel hat sich ins knie
geschossen und keine frage es gibt zwei
sprichwörter wo eto sechstes jahrhundert
hättest du doch geschwiegen wärst du
philosoph geblieben oder hat reden ist
silber schweigen ist gold
das wird man ihn so schnell nicht
verteilen die frage es gibt es einen
besseren kandidaten dass es noch nicht
ausgemacht in der fraktion gibt es zwei
das wahrscheinlich könnten aber haben
sie das vertrauen des vorstandes usw
sie haben vielleicht nennen wenn sie
sich ja häufig mit zu nicht und will
sagen die dass beide könnten natürlich
auch brigitte zypries könnte das mit
ihrer erfahrung aber ich glaube sie will
das nicht mehr
aber dann kommt dann auch wieder das
spiel ost west frauen es müssen
mindestens drei frauen seien und
andrea nahles bleibt in der fraktion
geht nicht ins kabinett
also das wird noch mal ein bisschen
spannend aber das ist jetzt glaube ich
für die spd nicht die entscheidende
frage sind die entscheidende frage ist
geht dieser mitgliederentscheid gut
sonst ist die ganze parteiführung
beschädigt die schon mit der kandidatur
oder mit der ankündigung von schulz
einen fehler gemacht hat ihm das
durchgehen zu lassen das hätte man dann
mittwoch stoppen oder verhindern müssen
da ist der ganze vorstand gefragt
gewesen und auch andrea nahles ein
bisschen beschädigt dadurch also das
wird nicht einfach mitgliederentscheid
was wird jetzt aus diesem
mitgliederentscheid ursprünglich wollte
schulz ja auch das außenamt übernehmen
um die große koalition zu prägen mit
seiner politik mit seinen europäischen
überzeugungen jetzt wird er
zurückgezogen um den mitgliederentscheid
überhaupt noch eine chance zu geben bei
den spd-mitgliedern was wird aus dem
jetzt eigentlich wie wir das weiter
geben also dass das unvorhersehbare
dieses mitgliederzahl das ist nicht weg
das bleibt so es ist eine völlig andere
situation als vor vier jahren die in den
mitgliedern oder unter den mitgliedern
gibt es in der große ablehnung gegenüber
der großen koalition
trotzdem glaube ich die situation für
die spd hat sich wesentlich verbessert
dadurch dass sie diese personalfrage
geklärt haben wenn sie das nicht getan
hätten dann hätte die personalie schulz
diesen mitgliederentscheid vollkommen
überlagert
man hätte tatsächlich nur noch darüber
geredet und das war ja wie
kommunizierende röhren diese debatte um
schuld also es waren immer wieder
stichwortgeber die sich gemeldet haben
und die gesagt haben schulz muss gehen
und dann ging es zur basis und dann
haben die mitglieder die die
abgeordneten wieder gesagt die basis
rede drüber und sich so hat sich das
immer weiter verstärkt das ist jetzt
nicht mehr so dieser dieses problem ist
gelöst für die spd insofern glaube ich
dass die chance dass sie über das doch
sehr gute verhandlungsergebnis leben
können jetzt wirklich gestiegen aber die
frage wird es sich jetzt wirklich auf
die inhaltliche diskussion dieses
koalitionsvertrags beziehen bei der im
vorfeld des mitgliederentscheids oder
überlagern diese personalfragen doch
diese entscheidung auch weil sich ja
eben gerade keiner in der spd-führung
immer mit mit ruhm bekleckert hat also
ich glaube
es gab ja zwei sehr unterschiedliche
strategien die strategie des vorstands
war
wir reden er nicht über die inhalte
sondern wir reden über die ressorts die
wir bekommen haben weil wir da wirklich
mit fug und recht sagen können da haben
einen großen erfolg erzielt durch die
drei schlüsselministerien die wir
bekommen haben und die jusos und die
parteilinken und ja sofort gesagt nein
im sommer verteilung wollen wir nicht
reden wir wollen über inhalte reden aber
wenn man über inhalte redet dann ist
natürlich das problem dass die spd quasi
bis zum sondierungs papier durchaus
sinnvolle ergebnisse erzielt hat
kompromisse die ihrer klientel gut tun
aber dann hat sie ja noch was drauf
gesattelt durch den sonderparteitag und
die bei den dreieck gebieten wo sie was
drauf gesattelt hat sie die ganze sache
ja nicht so toll aus man mit dem
familiennachzug hat sich eher die csu
durch chris bei bei der sachgrundlosen
befristung gab es ein kompromiss der
aber schwer zu verkaufen ist weil es
nicht das schlagwort gibt wir haben sie
abgeschafft und bei der
bürgerversicherung die tatsache dass man
kommission einsetzt heißt immer wir
haben uns nicht einigen können und
schieben sie auf die lange bank
das heißt da ist ja nicht wirklich drei
mal gepunktet worden bei genau den
sachen die jetzt wichtig sind weil sie
draufgesattelt wird
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt wie man
das verkauft als großen erfolg
mitgliederentscheid was wird jetzt aus
dem mitgliederentscheid könnte das der
no go kommt bewegung in der spd nach den
ereignissen des heutigen tages noch mal
helfen
also ich glaube in der spd gibt es schon
großes entsetzen was da passiert ist und
die fehler haben ja auch viel früher
angefangen also das finca bei der
bundestagswahl an also so hart wie das
ist aber wenn jemand 20,5 prozent
einfährt dann kann er nicht weitermachen
dann hat der wähler gesprochen und dann
haben sie sich immer weiter geschleppt
dann hat es diese sitzung gegeben die
nachtsitzung dann hat es in der einen
sitzung mal den versuch gegeben ihn dann
doch zum rücktritt zu drängen
dank
sich aber die leute nicht einigen wer
das machen soll
es ging dann immer hin und her und so
sind haben sie immer weiter sind sie da
reingestolpert und holen im grunde
genommen jetzt so ein bisschen das nach
was nach der bundestagswahl hätte
passieren müssen
als spd-mitglied kann man sich schon
finde ich auch die frage stellen
derjenige der schon auch also andrea
nahles hat vielfalt olaf scholz hat viel
verhandelt aber eben schulz hat auch
viel verhandelt
und der darf jetzt gar nichts mehr der
ist weg hat aber angeblich das ganze mit
durchverhandelt und hat eine auch eine
wende in europa politik erreicht wo
jetzt nicht mehr klar ist wer die
durchsetzen soll
das wirkt nicht wirklich
vertrauenswürdig die zukunft eine
stabile regierten republik liegt er im
moment in der hand von 450.000
spd-mitgliedern wenn die das jetzt hier
heute miterlebt haben das ist ja
zunächst mal eine innerparteiliche
angelegenheit was jetzt aus dem
koalitionsvertrag wird was die heute
hier miterlebt haben interessieren sich
die noch für die inhalte des
koalitionsvertrags für das was martin
schulz da am mittwoch als
sozialdemokratische handschrift
bezeichnet hat ja ich glaube die
interessieren sich mehr für die inhalte
also das ist mein empfinden auch meiner
kenntnis aus den ganzen berichten die
ich gesehen habe und mit den leuten mit
denen ich gesprochen habe in den orts
wahlen in den versammlungen geht es um
die inhalte und weniger um die posten
das wäre es gegangen wenn schulz
geblieben wäre aber das ist jetzt
abgeräumt von daher ist es gut dass über
die inhalte geredet wird und ich glaube
sie haben aus einem was gelernt aus den
letzten vier jahren dass sie besser
kommunizieren das und ich hoffe
jedenfalls dass ihnen das gelingt nicht
nur für die spd sondern für das land
weil das wenn das schiefgeht ist
deutschland wirklich an zwergen
territorium in europa mit dem keiner
mehr in den nächsten monaten rechnet
deswegen muss das gut gehen und deswegen
muss auch über die inhalte und das was
durch gesetz ist geredet werden und es
ist ja von den drei punkten die auch
drauf gesetzt worden sind mal abgesehen
viel erreicht worden und viel mehr
erreicht worden als oft jetzt in der
presse auch dargestellt wird weil die
kritikpunkte herausgezogen werden aber
ich glaube dass wenn man das ordentlich
vermittelt die mitglieder dass auch
kopieren müssten sage ich mal ob sich
die frage ist ja die frage ist ja jetzt
ist ein problem aus dem weg geräumt
worden nämlich schulz aber hat es noch
für möglich dass der mitgliederentscheid
scheitert natürlich ist es möglich also
dass hat sich ja vorhin gesagt ich es
ist eine völlig andere situation als vor
vier jahren da hat man bei ungefähr drei
viertel der mitglieder die dafür
gestimmt haben jetzt gibt es eine menge
neue eintritte die mutmaßlich dagegen
stimmen werden
viele von denen die möglicherweise dafür
sind bleiben vielleicht auch zu hause
bzw schicken die karte gar nicht ab und
fallen somit als pro stimmen weg das
heißt dass diese möglichkeit gibt es
noch aber noch einmal diese entscheidung
ist aus meiner sicht eine chance das
klar durchzuziehen und wieder diese
personaldebatten abzuschließen und
wieder zu den inhaltlichen debatten zu
kommen ich glaube einen punkt muss die
spd mal lernen das hat sie wirklich in
den vergangenen jahren einfach nicht
hingekriegt wenn die zweite reihe die
mächtige zweite reihe die direkt unter
dem parteivorsitzenden sitzt für sich
mehr oder weniger einig ist damit dass
der parteivorsitzende abgelöst werden
sollte und diese situation gab es nicht
nur bei martin schulz die gab es viele
jahre schon bei sigmar gabriel dann muss
diese reihe von features es schaffen
diese entscheidung durchzudrücken
das ist bei sigmar gabriel lange nicht
passiert viel zu lange nicht passiert
und das ist bei martin schulz in den
vergangenen wochen in den entscheidenden
momenten auch nicht passiert das in dem
moment in dem er gesagt hat ich gehe ins
kabinett sich die feeds es nicht
durchgesetzt haben und gesagt haben nein
diese entscheidung kann man so nicht
treffen die debatte wird weitergehen
das ist auch ein versagen der features
und das ist der das alte traum also es
gibt ja das spiel seht trauma der spd
deswegen ist ja gabriel über jahre nicht
los war der sturz von kurt beck wie
genau als müntefering und frank walter
steinmeier sich zusammengetan haben und
kurt beck aus dem spiegel erfahren
musste das denn
frank walter steinmeier der
kanzlerkandidat wird und ihm das aus der
hand genommen wurde er als
parteivorsitzender den nicht mehr
nominieren dürfte
und da hat seine tagung vom schwielowsee
gegeben und kurt beck hat die tagung
durch den hintereingang verlassen
hannelore kraft hat noch jahre später
tränen in den augen gehabt wenn die über
diese situation gesprochen hat und habe
gesagt so etwas darf sich nie wieder
wiederholen eine partei die die
solidarität groß schreibt darf nicht so
miteinander umgehen und jetzt haben sie
im grunde genommen den schwielowsee ja
fast noch also wiederholt oder ist sogar
noch schlimmer gemacht und das ist halt
auch was das wird nachwirkungen haben
weil das natürlich misstrauen rein seht
es wird jetzt die partei lange
beschäftigen
wer hat denn da eigentlich mit auch
gearbeitet der die strippen gezogen wer
wollte was also ist wäre nicht microchip
der nrw-vorsitzende alleine sondern ein
landesverband rennt auch dann los und
droht und macht druck wenn er das gefühl
hat dass andere ja das also ihn gewähren
lassen und das darf eben begrüßt wird
wenn genau das passiert nicht nur nrw
die hessen zu verstörung
die hatten ja gerade gesagt man kann das
straucheln der parteivorsitzenden der
spd in den letzten 20 jahren nicht
miteinander vergleichen das gab
unterschiedliche gründe aber warum hat
die spd so ein unglückliches händchen
bei der auswahl ihrer parteichefs also
ich glaube ja immer dass die spd eine
manisch-depressive partei ist sie ist
himmelhoch jauchzen und im nächsten
augenblick dann wieder zu tode betrübt
und das ist auch bezug auf ihre
vorsitzenden so sie hebt sie auf das
schild das ist alles ganz toll und
wunderbar und dann fängt nach relativ
kurzer zeit sofort die kritik an hier
und da
und man ist aber nicht konsequent genug
dass des öfteren und das zieht die sache
dann hin und das bringt bremst natürlich
dann auch den enthusiasmus der basis und
jetzt kommt jetzt nochmals dazu ich mein
11 verspricht martin schulz die partei
zu erneuern unter anderem dadurch also
der basis der partei auch mehr
mitspracherechte gibt das tun sie auch
in den inhalten und zwar so sozusagen
bis an den rand der verfassungsmäßigkeit
indem sie über den koalitionsvertrag
abstimmen lassen da sind ja ein paar
verfassungsrechtler durchaus uneins ob
das mit der repräsentativen demokratie
vereinbar ist aber lassen wir das mal
weg aber gleichzeitig gibt es dann
wieder diese hinterzimmer diplomatie im
bezug auf den vorsitzenden dass eine
kleine gruppe von leuten entscheidet und
vor entscheidungen und trifft wer jetzt
vorsitz abgibt und wer da nicht so
vorsitzender werden sollen das ist ja
auch der grund dafür dass es jetzt
diesen offenen brief gibt
der fordert dass der parteivorsitzende
per urwahl der mitglieder gewählt werden
soll also diese diskrepanz die ist jetzt
auch noch daten auch schon mal war auch
nicht das tollste ergebnis muss man ja
auch sagen aber das ist natürlich etwas
was noch jetzt dazu kommt dass die
mitglieder sagen wieso sollen wir
eigentlich über den koalitionsvertrag
abstimmen aber in bezug auf personal
dann haben wir nichts zu sagen zählt der
spd ein durchdachtes politisches
management also die spd leidet natürlich
auch darunter dass sie in der vergangen
seit wir im vergangenen jahrzehnt in
alle richtungen schon abgebogen ist den
die man politisch abbiegen kann
sie hat im grunde genommen in der
letzten dekade nach der agenda 2010 und
der sinnkrise in die sie verfallen ist
viele viele fragen nicht geklärt sie
weiß nicht ob sie eigentlich
klimaschützer sein möchte oder ob sie
eigentlich doch bei den kohle kumpels
noch hängt sie weiß nicht ob sie
eigentlich gegen die rüstungsexporte
sein möchte oder ob sie doch eher bei
den metallern und bei den werftarbeitern
steht und so las lässt sich die lassen
sich diese punkte vor fortsetzen
besonders in der flüchtlings und
migrationsfragen ist es ein
riesenproblem dass sie natürlich die
arbeiterschaft zum großen teil an die
fdp verloren haben
der anderen seite aber eigentlich
natürlich das weltbild einer
international offenen solidarischen
partei haben dass sie diese fragen nicht
geklärt haben in den letzten zehn jahren
liegt auch daran weil sie über viele
dieser jahre einen vorsitzenden hatten
der jede der position einmal eingenommen
hat sigmar gabriel hat es geschafft mit
einem refugees welt kam welcome sticker
in den bundestag zu kommen und
gleichzeitig mit pepita anhängern zu
sprechen der hat im grunde genommen über
jahre die partei irritiert und das ist
natürlich ein chaos in dem die spd sich
noch befindet dass martin schulz ein
stückweit geehrt hat das ja auch nicht
gelöst hat aber da muss die spd mal ran
die spd muss sich im grunde genommen
fast eine art kleines neues godesberger
programm geben um zu definieren was sie
eigentlich steht das ist die wichtigste
frage das hat aber natürlich auch einen
strukturellen hintergrund
denn mit der traditionellen
kernwählerschaft der
aufstiegsorientierten arbeiterschaft
allein kann man schon lange keine
mehrheiten mehr gewinnen also braucht
man sozusagen ein bündnis der jahr links
liberal orientierten mittelschicht mit
der alten kernwählerschaft und deshalb
meinen sich noch zum letzten mal 1998
geklappt mit dem wunderbaren slogan
innovationen und soziale gerechtigkeit
und auch neue mittel personell
unterfüttert und durch schröder und
lafontaine und seither hat es nicht
gelangt und die die werte bilder die
interessen die grundeinstellungen dieser
beiden gruppen die man eigentlich
zusammenbinden müsste um groß genug zu
bleiben die sind immer mehr auseinander
gedriftet gerade eben auch wegen der
globalisierung und dann haben wir noch
das problem dass sind ermittler und
führungsschicht also auch bei den
parteitagsdelegierten die links liberal
orientierte mittelschicht dominiert und
eben nicht die traditionelle
wählerschaft der spd und danach kriegen
sie so beschlüsse wie das man ab stellt
auf die europafrage auf die vereinigten
staaten von europa oder auf das problem
des familiennachzugs was die
traditionelle wählerschaft überhaupt
nicht interessiert
am anfang eher gegeben hat war halt das
also vorher es gabriel wie ein flummi
durch die gegend geschwitzt hat jede
position eingenommen
und dann kam plötzlich martin schulz und
der war innenpolitisch als ein weißes
blatt
man konnte jede hoffnung in dem raum
projizieren und dann kann er noch ganz
gut sprechen und dann war plötzlich der
heiland und dann merkte man danach kam
halt nicht ich glaube allerdings dass
das duo nahles scholz das vielleicht
sogar hinkriegen kann weil sie in einer
person eben nicht diese doch sehr
mittlerweile bereit auf gespaltene
gesellschaft einfangen können also im
grunde genommen war ja auch schröder und
lafontaine haben das ja auch gemacht die
haben ja beide pole bedient und mit dem
scholz und der nahles die ja immer noch
als dann eher links gilt und scholz der
dann der pragmatisch rechte ist könnte
das funktionieren wenn die eine
arbeitsteilung hinkriegen und deswegen
hat ja auch nahles sehr darauf
hingearbeitet dass scholz nach berlin
kommen aber politische freundschaften
das zeigt ja gerade das beispiel spd
können auch sehr glücklich werden nicht
nur gabriel unschuld das gab es auch
natürlich zwischen schröder und
lafontaine was macht sie so sicher dass
es möglicherweise zwischen alesund
scholz besser klappen könnte weil das
schon also die beiden haben jetzt schon
über relativ viele jahre engen kontakt
gehalten und diese brücke hat immer
funktioniert also in den ganzen
sitzungen wenn es darum ging wie geht es
weiter
soll jemand gestürzt werden oder nicht
haben die immer aufeinander geguckt und
die haben sich sind sich nicht
gegenseitig in den rücken gefallen
sondern die hatten immer den wunsch ist
zusammen zu machen und das hat zumindest
gehalten das ist keine garantie für die
für die zukunft arbeitet nur
funktionieren wenn gabriel nicht
dazwischen krebs schon genau deswegen
wollte man glauben sie herr gabriel ist
zukunft hinter sich jedenfalls als
parteisoldat oder parteiführer als
minister vielleicht nicht das wird man
sehen
da würde ich jetzt sagen das ist noch
nicht ganz entschieden aber er wird
keine renaissance einige der wird er
wird in der partei keine renaissance
erleben und ich gebe einem mann völlig
recht wirst du hat das internalisiert
auch durch die langen jahre im
parteiapparat scholz war generalsekretär
das war generalsekretär in die kennen
das spiel in der partei die partei ist
ja 100 mal schwieriger als die cdu wo es
nur um die macht geht bei der spd gibt
es in 20 fall nicht um die macht sondern
um die wahrheit und die können dann auch
noch verschiedene nuancen haben und ich
glaube dass das besser funktionieren
wird zumal nahles sich in den letzten
jahren so positiv verändert hat wenn man
das interview mit ihrer vorgestern bei
den kollegen von zdf gesehen hat dann
war da deutlich dass sie die staatsfrau
geworden ist und ich habe gestern mit
der cdu-abgeordneten zu mittag gegessen
in der cdu hat man angst vor ihr nicht
nur respekt da hat man angst dass sie
die spd in der tat zu einem machtfaktor
wieder machen könnte aber das hängt
natürlich auch von den inhalten ab die
dann bei der nächsten wahl ob sie in
zwei oder vier jahren ist glaubwürdig
vertreten die spd eigentlich erst dann
wieder auf dem weg der besserung wenn
sie mal gelernt hat ihre siege auch zu
feiern sie hat ja gesagt einen
koalitionsvertrag ergattern können das
zeigte die reaktion aus der union auch
warnungen aus der cdu wo sie ja doch
wofür ihre 20,5 prozent relativ viel
erreicht hat und jetzt wird das eben
wieder überlagert über diese diskussion
ist wieder nicht in der lage ihre
erfolge die sie hat quasi richtig gut zu
verkaufen wo sie das erst mal lernen
nicht dass mit dem hintern gleich wieder
einzureisen das und vorher mühsam
aufgebaut hat ja ganz sicher
sie muss besser kommunizieren das ist
eine kommunikations frage ich bin da
aber ehrlich gesagt auch ganz
optimistisch dass das mit nahles und mit
schals besser wird in alesund scholz
anders als gabriel und schulz haben
keine emotionale bindung mit einer
schulz und gabriel war das war eine
emotionale freundschafts ging auf und ab
die haben sich gestritten und dann haben
sich wieder umarmt bei scholz und banal
sehe ich eigentlich eine rationale
verbindung die denken beide analytisch
die verstehen
politische prozesse sehr gut die durch
denken dass bis zum ende eigentlich fast
so ein bisschen wie die bundeskanzlerin
ich glaube dass das management der spd
viel viel besser werden wird
und ich würde ihnen auch völlig zu
stimmen mit der analyse des andreas
das eine enorme entwicklung gemacht hat
nicht nur in den jahren in denen sie im
arbeitsministerium war
sie hat auch unglaublich gute letzte
wochen gehabt und man darf auch einen
punkt nicht vergessen
sie hat einen großen auftritt gehabt in
sieben minuten oder fünf minuten auf dem
parteitag im januar als sie zwei sachen
bewiesen hat sie hat bewiesen dass sie
auf dem parteitag die stimmung drehen
kann das hat man ihr teilweise nicht
zugetraut uns ja zum zweiten bewiesen
dass sie bis bis zur selbstaufgabe hätte
ich fast gesagt aber wirklich bis zu
einer weiten grenze loyal sein kann
jemandem gegenüber dem sie eigentlich
kritisch gegenüber steht nämlich martin
schulz sie hat ihnen in dem moment
gerettet und sie hat damit zwei dinge
bewiesen die sie beweisen musste und und
deswegen ist sie auch völlig kritiklos
jetzt eigentlich als designierte
parteivorsitzende bestimmt worden das
hätte man sich vor ein paar jahren
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können andrea
nahles war eine person die polarisiert
in dem moment in dem sie jetzt bekannt
als parteichefin nominiert wurde hat das
jeder als eine selbstverständlichkeit
angenommen das ist ein ergebnis von sehr
guten jahren im arbeitsministerium und
von sehr guten wochen und monaten jetzt
hat andrea nahles schon staatsfrau
qualitäten also ich will doch ein
bisschen davor waren das jetzt als das
neue dream team jetzt schon aussuchen
denn es gibt zwei probleme mit den
beiden das eine problem ist dass scholz
beim letzten parteitag deutlich
abgestraft wurde also in den parteien
nicht nur freunde und das zweite problem
ist die außenwirkung von andrea nahles
die ist noch nicht so dass man sagen
könnte wer in den augen der bevölkerung
in den augen der partei aber in den
augen der bevölkerung die starts freude
sind sie noch nicht ja und zwar
überhaupt noch nicht sie hat ungefähr so
schlechte werte wie martin schulz
momentan jetzt das kann sich natürlich
besser aber da muss ich noch dran
arbeiten
womit ist ja gerade schon angeklungen
womit muss jetzt zum beispiel angela
merkel eigentlich rechnen wenn es jetzt
zu dieser großen koalition kommen soll
in dieser neuaufstellung der spd
an der spitze gehen jetzt mal davon aus
andrea nahles wir tatsächlich
parteichefin sich ist ja auch
gleichzeitig in der fraktion dass
möglicherweise einen vizekanzler olaf
scholz geben womit muss sie da rechnen
jetzt auch was ihre eigene position
ihrer eigenen stellung angeht die ja
bisher relativ unangefochten war in
einer bundesregierung also merkel und
scholz haben ja schon einmal
zusammengearbeitet in einem kabinett
scholz war ja schon mal arbeitsminister
die kennen sich die schätzen sich auch
scholz ist ein harter verhandler
aber ich glaube für frau merkel ist sehr
viel einfacher jetzt mit andrea nahles
und olaf scholz leute zu haben die sie
schätzt und von denen sie dann glaubt
dass die durchsetzungskraft haben als
jemanden als gegenüber zu haben weil das
war ja auch das schwierige in den
koalitionsverhandlungen das ist ein
parteivorsitzenden gab der aber ja ganz
viel gar nicht verhandeln konnte oder
durfte oder sich rückkoppeln musste das
macht es ja sehr sehr viel schwieriger
wenn sie mit jemandem zusammen sitzende
vereinbarung treffen wollen und nicht
wissen kann der die überhaupt einhalten
insofern glaube ich dass es da keine
großen probleme erstmal im normalen
regierungsalltag gibt und vor allem muss
die große koalition wenn der
mitgliederentscheid durch geht muss er
erstmal auch im arbeitsmodus kommen und
da wollen die leute glaube ich dann
nicht sofort permanenten streit sondern
dann müssen die liefern und gesetze
verabschieden und projekte vorantreiben
das wird ein härteres ringen jetzt
werden weil beide parteien abgestraft
wurden oder alle drei parteien bei der
bundestagswahl die csu wird sich bis zur
bund bis zur landtagswahl noch sehr wild
auf führen also das halte ich dann für
also wenn es denn die große koalition
gibt es bis dahin für den größeren
unruhe faktor weil die alles tun müssen
um irgendwie ein akzeptables ergebnis in
bayern zu holen was eben auch richtig
schiefgehen kann also mit einer starken
fdp mit freien w
und so weiter deshalb glaube ich dass
die mit merkel ganz gut auskommen das
sind alles erstmal pragmatische
politiker es gibt ja eine verpflichtung
also nach einer regierungsbildung eine
verpflichtung zur kooperation zur
zusammenarbeit warum gebe es sonst auch
eine koalition aber das ist immer so als
sei das eine selbstverständlichkeit im
hinterkopf ist ja immer noch dabei was
ist am ende dieser großen koalition bei
der nächsten auseinandersetzung bei der
nächsten bundestagswahl inwieweit wird
diese überlegung da gibt es ja
möglicherweise nicht nur bei der spd
veränderungen sondern eben auch bei der
union inwieweit schwingt diese
überlegung immer in der alltäglichen
regierungsarbeit mit die wird mit
spenden spätestens wenn man zur halbzeit
bilanz zieht das kann ja sein dass es
dann zum bruch kommt aber es wird in den
letzten beiden jahren sind noch drei
eigentlich jetzt wird es sich zu spät
sind keine frage aber ich glaube ist das
funktionieren teile die auffassung kann
man andrea nahles ist wenn sie cdu leute
fragen minister fragen
fraktionsvorsitzenden die personen die
ministerin die am meisten beachtet wurde
nach anfänglichen skepsis weil sie an
sich an alles gehalten hat man mit ihr
alle verabredungen treffen konnte und
scholz merkel war die einzige die scholz
in schutz genommen hat nach dem g 20
gipfel noch nicht mehr aus der eigenen
partei kamen da große unterstützung also
das wird erst mal funktionieren aber zur
hälfte der legislaturperiode wird sich
die reibungshitze erhöhen das muss dann
auch so sein
und wenn die spd nicht noch weiter
abfallen will muss sie dann profil
zeigen gegenüber auch dem großen
koalitionspartners wird ihr leichter
fallen weil angela merkel dann lame duck
ist und die nachfolge möglicherweise
auch noch nicht entschieden ist in der
cdu so hoch
feige wie ihn manche da sind kann sich
das ja durchaus bis kurz vor dem ende
hin ziel ist natürlich eine sache sagen
die hitze bei angela merkel ist schon
enorm erhöht wenn heute nicht der
rücktritt oder der rückzug von martin
schulz gewesen wäre hätten wir hier eine
führungsrunde zur bundeskanzlerin machen
können denn wir haben erstmals
eigentlich die situation dass die
nachfolgefrage von angela merkel nicht
mehr virtuell ist sondern sie ist da es
sind cdu abgeordnete die sich gegen sie
auf lehnen die öffentlich sie
kritisieren die die ergebnisse der
koalitionsverhandlungen kritisieren und
das ist brutal gefährlich das ist
besonders deshalb gefährlich weil die
spd den großteil ihrer probleme jetzt
erstmal gelöst hat so ob das alles sind
wissen wenn ich aber der nächste punkt
wird die frage sein nachdem sich die csu
halbwegs erneuert hat und die spd sich
halbwegs erneuert und die grünen sich
halbwegs erneuert haben was ist
eigentlich mit der cdu wir werden ab
morgen auf die bundeskanzlerin gucken
und wie sich das weiter bewegt und
dieses ergebnis der
koalitionsverhandlung wird ihnen noch
nachhängen und vielleicht müssen wir gar
nicht zwei jahre warten bis diese
debatte ganz ganz heiß und ganz ganz
viele landwirte stellt sich ja gleich
die frage nach der stabilität dieser
koalition wenn sie denn zustande kommt
das klingt ja so als würde man ja auch
ständig sondern um die eigene existenz
bangen müssen kann man da eine sinnvolle
eine zukunftsgerichtete konstruktiven
regierungsarbeit leisten stehen ja eine
menge probleme ins haus die gelöst
werden müssen ja eben das ist es ja ich
meine man kann ja eine regierungsarbeit
auch nicht nur unter parteipolitischen
gesichtspunkten wie kommen wir am
schnellsten wieder raus betrachten
sondern man muss ja auch sehen dass es
tatsächlich eine ganze reihe größerer
probleme gibt die man lösen muss die die
koalitionen anpacken muss und diese auch
deswegen anpacken muss um dann wieder
vor die wähler treten zu können und
sagen zu können dass und das haben wir
geleistet und vielleicht glaubt dass ja
auch mal dass die spd dann auch
tatsächlich mal stolz darauf ist was sie
in einer koalition durchgesetzt hat
statt immer dran rum zu meckern und zu
sagen
im prinzip wollen wir eigentlich nicht
regieren weil
beim regieren immer kompromisse machen
müssen und wir wollen ja eher die reinen
lehre durchsetzen wenn man das ändert
wenn man tatsächlich positiv
kommuniziert dann hat man auch größere
chancen und die sollbruchstelle ist
tatsächlich denke ich in zwei jahren
aber erst in zwei jahren hatte ich
glaube nicht dass frau merkel vorher
wirklich gefährdet ist sie ist
geschwächt
nicht nur als zwei gestern oder seit den
letzten wochen sondern seit dem herbst
2015 wo ihre werte deutlich
runtergegangen sind in der bevölkerung
in bezug auf die flüchtlingsfrage und
sie hat sich davon nie wirklich erholt
und aber andererseits ist es ebenso es
ist keine alternative dar die sich jetzt
schon auf trinkt das wird niemand die
wir gelegenheit ergreifen und sagen ich
stelle mich jetzt wirklich von denen in
der ersten reihe gegen frau merkel offen
und fordere sie heraus das wird nicht
passieren
und insofern liegt es an ihr ihre
nachfolge in einer halbwegs sinnvolle
weise zu organisieren und das ist schwer
genug und sie hat bisher alle die
mögliche nachfolgerinnen oder nachfolger
waren mit unterschiedlichen macht
techniken davon abgehalten ihren
vorgängern wird mir nie gelungen ist
seit 1949 seit adenauer ist ja dass man
freiwillig geht bzw
das timing des ausstiegs selbst bestimmt
wird ihr das gelingen ist sie da kinder
eigentlich gehört das auch nicht in
einer demokratie weil da geht es schon
um das bundeskanzleramt also um den
höchsten job und das sind menschen die
müssen härteste verhandlungen mit
anderen staatschefs in brüssel und
sonstwie führen
die müssen kämpfen können und ich glaube
auch dass die spd daran ein bisschen
gekränkt hat die letzten
kanzlerkandidaten haben nicht wirklich
ausgestrahlt das also auch steinbrück
steinmeier als ob sie wirklich alles
dafür tun können das war schröder
schröder hat an an dem zaun gerüttelt
und sie müssen sich in einer solchen
position das stück fleisch selbst vom
teller ziehen können das hat an
merkel übrigens auch getan die hat
nämlich als generalsekretär in helmut
kohl gestürzt so diesen machtwillen und
auch diese härte müssen sie glaube ich
einmal beweisen das geht nicht auf dem
silbertablett dass irgendjemand wie in
einer monarchie sich seinen thronfolger
aussucht und sagt du wirst das jetzt
andrea nahles und olaf scholz diese
hätte diesen bis sich das stück fleisch
vom teller zu ziehen die haben sie würde
ich sagen was ihre bisherige praxis
angeht
ich würde aber auch die prognose wagen
wenn jetzt nicht irgendetwas
unvorhergesehenes passiert dann ist
andrea nahles diejenige die den hut in
den ring werfen wird und die die
kanzlerkandidatin sein wird in vier
jahren oder in zwei jahren und hat sie
chancen
ich würde ja gegen jemanden antreten die
sie möglicherweise noch gar nicht kennt
wenn angela merkel nicht was man
erwartet nicht noch mal kandidiert wie
sind ihre chancen in zwei bis drei
jahren schwer zu sagen weil wir nicht
wissen gegen wen sie antreten würde
davon hängt natürlich vieles ab und weil
wir nicht wissen wie diese
koalitionsarbeit läuft andrea nahles hat
das haben wir vorher schon mal einen
einmal angesprochen
bei allen vorzügen und bei all der guten
präzisen akribischen arbeit die sie
geleistet hat das problem dass sie für
viele in der bevölkerung nicht gewinnt
wirkt aber andrea nahles ist enorm
lernfähig die hat vieles vieles von
ihren spiele von ihren schwächen
aufgearbeitet und verbessert und ich
würde gar nicht ausschließen dass sie
auch in dem bereich noch enormes
aufholen kann
das ist aber wirklich alles eine frage
die wird in den nächsten zwei jahren
verhandelt und wenn sie sich da gut
schlägt dann kann sie auch eine
ernstzunehmende kanzlerkandidaten werden
wir waren ja seit 140 tagen auf eine
regierung auf eine regierungskoalition
viele aus der politik haben ja den
eindruck vermitteln als wollten sie
nicht so richtig regieren als würde
nichts zusammenpassen dass man nicht
wirklich an einer regierungsbildung
interessiert ist es wurden viele wollten
geschlagen und viele finden eingelegt
ganz anders der bevölkerung langsam
das auch bisher stets gesagt eigentlich
wir haben auch gar keinen bock mehr auf
eine große koalition
das zeigt ja die umfrage entwicklung
dass die geduld so langsam am ende ist
obwohl man ja sagen muss diese zweiten
koalitionsverhandlung das waren die
kürzesten jemals das darf man nicht
vergessen die verhandlungen 2013 haben
glaube ich um die drei vier monate
gedauert diesmal sagen es zweieinhalb
wochen also das war schon sehr sehr kurz
aber es vergaben natürlich diesen
vorlauf mit im prinzip wahlabend schon
beginnend mit der abklärung einer großen
koalition der sondierung war muss man
dazu ja gut aber man muss eben auch
sagen dass wir jetzt in
umbruchsituationen im parteiensystem
haben und jetzt koalition ausprobiert
werden mussten in bezug auf jamaika
die es auf der bundesebene vorher noch
nie gab und dass es dann zunächst einmal
etwas schwieriger wird und die parteien
länger brauchen um zusammenzufinden und
es inhalt ist problematischer wird das
war eigentlich vorauszusehen und
insofern war das scheitern auch nie
ausgeschlossen
das war ganz klar und bei der spd ist es
eben so dass die bisherigen erfahrungen
zumindest so gedeutet werden als schade
dass der partei immer dramatisch wenn
sie eine große koalition als
juniorpartner geht obwohl das empirisch
gar nicht stimmt einmal hat es geschadet
ein anderes mal hat er genutzt
das darf man nicht vergessen aber es
wird so in die welt gesetzt ist schadet
immer der spd wenn wir sind freiheiten
das letzten jahren bundesrepublik das
ist heute vorbei andere andere probleme
und andere parteien
und wir haben auch ein anderes
rezeptions verhältnis von politik und
eine verunsicherung bei den bürgern die
prognosen wer profitiert von was völlig
obsolet machen also das ist heute nicht
mehr zu sagen als angela merkel
vielleicht auch jetzt nachgegeben weil
der bei der verhandlung über den
koalitionsvertrag auch was die
ressourcen geht um neuwahlen zu
verhindern
nicht weniger in hinsicht darauf dass
die union schlecht abschneiden könne
sondern dass es möglicherweise ein
ergebnis gibt das wirklich das
parteiengefüge
aus der statik bringt und es ihr noch
sehr viel schwieriger macht überhaupt
noch irgendwelche bündnisse zu schmieden
dass das land möglicherweise dann erst
recht regierungsunfähig geworden wäre
das kann gut sein und vor allen dingen
hat angela merkel hätte sich dann die
frage stellen müssen also man kann sich
ja christian lindner hat den
verhandlungstisch verlassen
aber wenn dann auch die spd auch den
verhandlungstisch verlassen hat dann
hätte sie als zweimal eine regierung
nicht hinbekommen dann wäre halt auch
noch einmal einen schwung anfragen
losgegangen sie wäre ja nicht als
strahlende siegerin und großartige
kanzlerkandidatin dann in die nächsten
neuwahlen reingezogen also bei dem
gemacht was es in der union gibt die
union verzeiht nichts weniger als wenn
man nicht die macht erhält und das hätte
sie dann zweimal in verhandlungen nicht
geschafft deshalb musste sie also ihr
persönliches schicksal hängt davon ab
das war ja das finde ich das ist das
grundproblem dieser
koalitionsverhandlungen gewesen mit
schulz seehofer und merkel saßen bei
drei parteichefs am tisch die eigentlich
um ihre eigene zukunft gekämpft aber die
ist nicht nur um persönliche schicksale
sondern auch um stabilität für diese
frage ja sie wissen nicht was bei
neuwahlen raus kommt ja und das dass das
bei einer neuwahl jetzt dann ganz
hässlich ergebnis herauskommen das kann
sein ja wohl aber auch das kalkül ein
bisschen der fdp dass man merkel
vielleicht jetzt loswerden würde und
wenn sie jetzt wieder gescheitert wäre
wäre sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
angetreten sie hat halt um ihre eigene
zukunft vor allen dingen auch verhandelt
die wäre sonst gescheitert vielleicht
klappt getrieben nur noch eine minute
das problem sie hat ein vorurteil
bestätigt und das vorurteil ist dass sie
alles bereit ist abzugeben um die macht
zu erhalten und in dem fall ist es
ebenso sichtbar bei den ministerien
gewesen
ein stück zu weit wie ich finde da ist
sie zu weit gegangen und deswegen hat
sich jetzt auch die problematisiert aber
um die machtausübung braucht sie auch
etwas in der analyse kann ich alles
abgeben um die macht zu erhalten weil
sie sagen sie hat einfach zu viel
abgegeben sie muss ja diese macht auch
noch ausüben können zum beispiel
politikern aus der eigenen partei die
sie unterstützen in der regierungsarbeit
ja absolut ich kann nicht nur diesen
tweet wieder vom anfang zitieren zum
glück haben wir noch das kanzleramt ja
das braucht so macht ausüben vielmehr
anderes möchte was irgendwann ist nicht
geblieben
also wir lernen mit dem heutigen tagen
mal wieder das volk wählt die politiker
und die blicke bedanken sich dann damit
dass sich das volk in atem halten das
registrieren wir hier natürlich bei der
phoenix runde auch ganz genau ich
bedanke mich dass sie daran die mit
zuschauer bleiben sie bei phoenix
[Musik]